Judaism false also.
>> Yeah, but that's not the topic today.
>> Of course it's not. Of course not.
Of course not. Okay, I'm out of here.
You're out of here,
bro. These these guys, man. You can hear
him like force out that laugh.
I had to be regime.
All right,
let's see if we could get a um an actual
human up here who's not gin possessed.
Let's bring up H.
Somebody said Count Dracula laugh.
Flamethrower says justice for Aisha.
Man, justice for Aisha, man.
>> Hello.
>> Hello there.
>> What's going on, man?
>> Nothing much, man. Nothing much. What's
your religion, bro?
>> I'm Muslim.
>> All right. All right. Welcome to the
stage. What would you like to uh engage
with here?
>> I just want to see why it says Islam is
false. What's your perspective on this?
>> Yeah. So um I say Islam is false because
there are some claims that it makes uh
that are detrimental internally to it.
So for example it says that we can find
Muhammad mentioned in the gospel and
obviously he's nowhere to be found and
so that would show that Islam is is
false. And then secondly it says that
the Bible is true while contradicting
the Bible at the same time which means
that the Quran is false. Well, the Bible
was also changed many times, which was
proven as well.
>> How dare you say that?
>> It's the truth, man. I'm not daring to
say anything. You're stating your facts
and I'm stating mine.
>> So, you mean to tell me that all
multiple times?
>> So, all I was So, all I was wrong, I got
you. So, all I was wrong when he said no
one could change his words.
>> He wasn't wrong. He said no one is
allowed to.
>> No, he didn't say no one is allowed to.
He said it's impossible. He saidnone can
alter. None can. Meaning nobody has the
ability to alter his words.
>> So let me ask you something. Why wasn't
the Quran ever altercated?
>> How do you know it wasn't?
>> I know it wasn't. It's been the same for
a very long time.
>> All right. So how So that's my thing
then. If you're saying that the Quran
has been the same for a very long time,
which it wasn't, but that's I mean
that's another tempting topic to get
into. But just to stay focused on what
we're talking about here, if you want to
say that the Quran was a stat was has
been the same for the for a very long
time. But Allah's other books like the
Torah and Gospel, they've been changed.
That would mean that Allah was not
telling the truth when he said none can
change his words.
You get what I'm saying?
>> Yeah, I get what you're saying. Um, kind
of sounds stupid to me, but
>> why? Like tell tell me. I'm like, I'm
curious.
>> How you blaming the whole religion for
whatever [__] y'all did with the
Bible?
>> Wait, dude. Relax. I'm I'm talking about
Allah. You don't got to cuss at me. I'm
talking about Allah, man. Well, tell me
what what sounds stupid about me saying
that I trust what Allah says. I trust
when Allah says none can change his
words, I believe him. And so therefore,
I don't believe the Torah is corrupted.
I don't believe the the gospel's
corrupted because Allah said none can
change his words. How is it stupid for
me to believe that?
>> Uh to be very honest with you, I don't
even know what type of time you want,
dude.
>> I'm on that I'm on that I'm on that that
Quran time, man. I'm on that for man.
>> Definitely not.
>> Tell me what's what's tell me what's
stupid about that position.
I mean, dude, to each their own, man. To
each their own, dude.
>> I know, but you said that. You said that
that's stupid. Meaning that you had a
thought process behind it, thinking
saying that, you know, this doesn't make
sense. What doesn't make sense about the
me taking the position of trusting what
Allah says? Why is it stupid for me to
trust what Allah says?
>> I didn't tell you that it's stupid for
you to trust what God says, but at the
end of the day, it's been proven many
times that the Bible has been changed.
So,
>> so Allah, so Allah's wrong.
>> I mean, bro,
>> say it. Say Allah's wrong. I'll go with
you on that.
>> No, no, I ain't saying all that. That's
That's not what
>> then then Allah was right. Then the
Bible's not changed and Allah's correct.
His words cannot be altered. Right.
>> Well, the only book that was vouched
for. The last book that was created was
the Quran, which hasn't been changed.
So, if the only book that hasn't been
changed is the Quran, then that means
Allah was wrong because his words can be
changed, right?
>> No, that's not what I'm saying.
>> You see the You see the trouble you're
in? See, I'm listening to Allah. You're
denying Allah while act while also
trying to act like you're on his side.
I'm more on Allah's side than you are,
bro.
Dude, whatever, man. You got it.
>> I know. I got it. Come to the Lord, man.
I offer you a better a better way than
this, man. You do not have to like be
stuck like this. I'm telling you. Come
to Christianity. It makes sense. Leave
Islam, bro. He dropped off, guys. He's
out of here. But man, that was fun. What
a what a good first guest that was,
right?
Goofy. Goofy.
With every guest that I bring up, I have
to take a sip of my
my protein smoothie. Straight path.
You're on the stage.
>> Okay. So, you're talking about Islam
that your guys came your guy came out of
Ismelly [__] Then you talk about
Islam.
>> What' you say?
>> Your guy came out of Ismelly [__] then.
What is up with these dudes, bro?
Oh, man.
The crazy part about it is that they
don't have the right accent to be
talking like that, man.
You don't sound right talking like that,
bro. Like that that's not how you should
be talking, man.
Like really, you you do not sound like
you should say that. You shouldn't be
talking like that, bro.
Oh my god. Like you could I like I know
you weren't raised to talk like that. I
like you were not you're not that type
of dude. You you're not you're not from
that, you know? Wow. Maybe you should
say it in your native tongue. You might
sound a little bit more I don't know.
about it. You know what I'm saying? But
you speaking English and saying it like
that.
>> Yeah, man. I'm telling you,
that is funny, man. These people,
these How do I reach these kids, y'all?
How do I reach these kids? All right,
let's uh let's see who else we got, man.
Uh, Rizzo's been saying he want to come
up.
My goodness.
>> Rizzo, what's up with you?
>> What's going on, brother?
>> What's up, brother? Peace. Peace. How
you doing, man?
>> Pretty good, man. Pretty good. What
What's your religion, brother?
>> I'm Muslim, brother.
>> Born and raised. Born and raised.
>> Yes, sir. Yes, sir.
>> Okay. What kind of What kind
>> Real Orthodox Muslim?
>> Okay. Yeah, I was just about to ask.
>> I actually Muslim. So, so, uh,
perspectively, brother, just want to ask
you just a quick quick question. So, you
know, I know we're here for
entertainment purposes and educational
purposes only,
>> right? Respect. You know, I get that.
But if once we have this dialogue,
>> right?
>> If I say something that may rub you the
wrong way, but still being respectful,
like not not like I'm gonna be real
respectful. I'm saying, but something
that you may not agree with, right? Are
you going you going to drop me
immediately or will we be able to hash
it out a little bit?
>> Here's my only thing. My only my only
thing is is that you remain direct. Be
direct.
>> Okay.
>> And be and be on topic and be
respectful. Those are only three things
that I that I ask for. If you're direct,
if you're on topic, and you're
respectful, we can talk as long as you
want.
>> I can dig it. I can dig. And listen, if
a if a brother is claiming to be a
Muslim, that should be real easy to do.
So, you know, so when I when I hear uh
when I hear individuals come up and they
they disrespectful and they get real
slanderous, then I said, you know, this
isn't this is this isn't a dialogue.
This is, you know, we aren't learning
and uh and building each other. This is,
you know, we just we just tearing each
other down. And I'll be honest with you,
I'm not really into that. You know what
I mean? But I am all in for having a,
you know, a conversation that could be
beneficial to both parties and the
people that's tuning in and listening.
>> Amen. All right. Oh, also, uh, fourth
thing, sorry. And you gotta be honest as
well. Gotta be honest. Gotta be honest.
Like
>> that's the only way to be.
>> Amen. All right. So, what's on your
mind? Islam is false. Quran confirms the
Bible. Which one you want to go into?
>> Okay. Well, well, I I do first want to
tell the people that these I mean it's a
great it's a pretty old dispute. This is
a pretty old dispute. Wars have been far
new. I mean, we got a been a lot of
things has happened during the course of
history. Uh, you know, involving the
people of the books. Who do I mean when
I say the people of the books? I'm
talking about the the Jews, the
Christians, and the Muslims. Because
people us all all three of these
denominations, all three of these
Abrahamic faiths, correct? Right. They
love their books and they hold on to
their books because, right, because the
books is really like all we really got
for real, right? Is the books
>> to go off of, right?
>> And I guess that's where some some level
of faith has to come in, right? So when
we do that I'm ask can I ask you first
what to say something is false
right then you would have to have an
extensive
you know research into into Islam like
you would have to know about it you can
just claim something to be false if you
don't you know if you have a small
>> absolutely correct
>> right that that wouldn't be intelligent
that wouldn't be intelligent I will tell
you this right
>> so I've done my I've done my sorry I
didn't mean to cut you off but I've done
>> no go ahead I've done my research. I've
done I've done my due diligence. Of
course, I don't know everything. I still
research. I still learn. I still study.
>> But from what I've seen and what I've uh
learned so far, I think that without a
shadow of a doubt, Islam is false
because
>> of the reason right here that I hear I
have right here that the Quran claims to
confirm the Bible.
>> And since it makes that claim that the
Bible is true,
>> that these are books from God. Well,
when I look at the Bible, I see a very
different message than what I see in the
Quran. I see Jesus is Lord. I see Jesus
is the son of God. I see that Jesus was
crucified for my sins and rose again
three days later. And the Quran
contradicts all of these things.
Therefore, I have to judge that the
Quran is false.
>> Okay. Okay. Just based off that one off
that one aspect or is there or is there
many more?
>> There's many more, but this is the main.
This is the main one.
>> Okay. That's the main one. Okay. Okay.
I'm not going to Well, interesting. And
the reason why I say it's interesting
like like my mother's African, right? My
mom is Ethiopian. So my my mom my mom's
Muslim like my father's side of the
family is just just regular
African-American from here. So my my
father's side of the family uh stone
cold Christian, you feel me? Uh so I I
kind of know about both religions, you
know, pretty, you know, you know, pretty
well, right? Uh
I will say this that that is where that
is where uh the separation is at right
there. Right. When when I when I hear
about these uh you know that's that's
that's like the biggest thing for
Christians. It's like how can you deny
Jesus? And it's like while at the same
time the Quran affirms these it affirms
these books
>> well
>> but contradicts these books. It it does,
but but it also but it also uh says it
it does not confirm it in its entirety
though.
>> Oh yes, it's in it. It's in it. It's in
its entirety. Brother, the Quran says
this, bro. In chapter 2, verse 85, Allah
hates
>> Allah hates it annoys him. It it grinds
his gears. Those who pick and choose
parts of the scripture they want to
believe in. Chapter 2 verse 85 says
this. says, "Do you thus believe in part
of the scripture while rejecting the
rest?
>> Those who do so among you are disgraced
in this life and have the severe
punishment waiting for them in the
hereafter." So Allah, he does not like
when people don't believe in the
entirety. So yes, when he says he
confirms the books, he confirms the
entirety of them. He never says part of
them.
>> Okay. No, no, no. Well, that's that's
that's debatable, but that's not true.
It ain't debatable.
>> So, so, so wait, so wait a minute. We
gonna get back to you. I'm going to ask
you. So, you mean to tell me?
>> We right here, dog.
>> So, so you mean to tell me
>> that that that the book that came to my
the book that Muhammad transcribed,
right? This Quran mean it was confirmed
in the King James version? That's
impossible,
>> right? So, didn't say anything. I didn't
say anything about the King James
version. Whoa, whoa, whoa. My brother,
just roll with me for a minute. Roll
with me for a minute.
>> You just asked a question. Hey dear
brother,
>> I know I got you. But listen, dear, I'm
not a slow thinker. I heard I heard it.
I No, I heard it. I heard it. No, I
heard it.
>> I'm gonna tell you this and all this is
going to make sense, right? Hopefully.
But but here's the thing.
>> You said the past point was debatable,
bro.
>> So So you want you want, man, man, we
gonna lose out on something good. You
want to debate on that?
>> This is this is huge because cuz you're
you're you're under the impression that
the Quran only confirms part of the
scripture. Oh, I'm know if if you let me
just land this plane and it's going to
make sense to you.
>> Okay.
>> So, you said you you said you have
studied and you know about and you know
about the dean. So, then that means you
do you do you know about tapsier, right?
>> Of course,
>> you know tapier.
>> Okay. So, you're not giving me the taps.
No,
>> it's not the tapsier. Okay. Okay. Okay.
So, we're going to do tapsier because
here's the thing. Here's the thing. Why
people need to understand this and this
goes for any and every book.
>> No. No. Why? Why? Why do we need taps
for clear verses?
>> What do you mean you need No, no, no,
no, no, no, sir. That's not how that
goes.
>> What do you mean?
>> That's not how that goes.
>> The Quran The Quran says it's a detailed
explanation of everything, doesn't it?
>> No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
>> It doesn't.
>> Listen, Tapsier is the explanation for
the explanation.
>> You got the defense. Hold on. Hold on.
You got the high def. I'm trying to give
it to you correctly, but go ahead. Go
ahead. I'm trying to give it to you the
right way, but go ahead. I I I want I
want I want you to know that you're
you're talking to a brother that and I
mean this humbly. I'm I'm not saying I'm
big-headed at all, brother. I know about
Islam, man. I know about Islam. I know
about the top. I know about the Hadith.
I know about your authentic Hadith. I
know about all of this.
>> Okay.
>> Why do I tell authentic?
>> So tell me.
>> Okay.
>> If Why Hold on, Rizzo? Listen.
>> I don't have it taps here in front of
me. I don't have
>> I need you to listen to my question,
brother. I need you to listen to my
question.
>> Stop. I don't have it in front of me.
Can you hear me?
>> I can hear you.
>> Okay. I need you to tell me why
when Allah says that he does not like
people who pick and choose and
cherrypick and believe in part of his
scripture that had this partial idea of
his scripture, not believing in its in
its entirety.
Why is it that you then are saying the
opposite and that Allah only confirms
part of the scripture? Why are you not
what I'm saying?
>> You keep saying that. I never said that.
>> You said you said you said it doesn't
confirm its entirety.
>> Listen to what I'm saying. Listen to
what I'm saying.
>> I'm listening.
>> You say you know you say you know about
Islam. Extensive. This is what you said.
So if that's the case, you know how you
know we have Listen, we have disputes
among ourselves the brothers dog. Like
like we like we have dispute. I've seen
brothers come down to blows about some
of the smallest brother. That's not
relevant to my question right now, man.
Remember remember remember I said direct
honesty on topic.
>> What I'm saying to you is this. When we
when we have disputes and we don't
understand certain things and one
brother is saying this means that and
saying no this means this then you
should know that you have the hadith and
you have the taps. Okay,
>> that's it. That's all. That's what this
is for. I got you.
>> And that's the truth.
>> I got you. So in a when a verse says
something like
whoever believes in part of the
scripture and rejects other parts is
going to hell.
Can some can that mean other something
else other than what it just said or am
I like dumb? Am I slow? Am I missing
something in the in the statement? Help
me out. Am I am I incapable of
understanding what that just said? Do I
need somebody else to tell me and
clarify what do you believe in part of
the scripture and reject the other
parts? If you do that, you're disgraced
in this life and you're going to go to
hell in the next. Do I need somebody to
come explain that to me?
>> Well, go. So, so go ahead and keep
reading. Go ahead and keep reading it.
What What is is it talking about what
scriptures? What scriptures is it says?
It's not talking about Injil. Is it
talking about Torah? What What is it
saying?
>> I got you. So in in context, I'm telling
you in context, he's talking about the
Jews
>> who are obeying part of God's
commandments, but rejecting the
commandments that go against them.
>> And so he's reprimanding them and then
lays out a general principle. A general
principle. Do you believe in part of the
scripture and reject the rest? Those who
do so are disgraced in this life. That
means you do that with any of his
scriptures. If you pick
>> No, you just said that. No, no, no, no,
no. You just said that means you do. No,
no, no, no, no. You just told him he was
talking to the Jews. You're right. Just
like just like Jesus was talking to the
Jews. Jesus was talking to the Jews.
>> Okay. So, so can I I got you. So, when I
read the Quran, can I because that verse
is specifically about the Jews and what
they're doing.
>> Can I take the Quran, believe in part of
it, and reject other parts that I don't
like? Can I do that?
>> No. Why not?
>> No. You do what I just You do what I
just told you. If if if you do not have
a clear interpretation or a clear
meaning, you you go to the tapsier. If
you can't do the taps, you get to the
hadith. If you can't do neither of
those, you try to consult a scholar. You
can't do that. That's not answering my
question. That's not answer my question.
>> Why can't I wait? Listen.
>> Why can't I pick up a Quran?
Why can't I pick up my Quran, open it
up, pick a verse like, for example,
chapter 4 verse 171 where it says, "Do
not excess in your religion, but only
say the truth about Allah." that Jesus
Quran.
>> Of course,
>> this is a noble Quran.
>> That Jesus that Jesus that Jesus, the
son of Mary, Jesus is the son of Mary
>> is a messenger of Allah and his word
>> that he sent down to Mary and a spirit
from him. Right.
>> That's right.
>> I like that part. I like No, no, no. I
love it.
>> I don't I don't I don't want to keep
going because when I keep going, it then
says, "Do not say three."
>> Okay. But listen, but I don't like I
don't like that part. I don't like that
part.
>> Okay. Okay. But you Christian don't even
rock with the trinity though, brother. I
mean I mean that's a person that's
that's a personal thing. So that's a
personal thing. Am I okay in picking
part of the verse that I believe in and
rejecting the rest of the verse?
>> You you know why you would be okay?
Because your covenant is with you and
your Lord anyway. So So of course you
would be okay.
>> So I'm good with God.
>> I'm good in the eyes of Allah. If I
reject if I reject
>> I can't speak for God because I I I
don't I don't have a God's
consciousness. I can't speak for God.
>> He already spoke.
>> But but what but but what I'm saying is
this. The covenant is with man and his
Lord, not with man the world. Like it
doesn't matter. So So I want to ask you
missing the point, bro. Go ahead.
>> No, I'm not. Is is Allah okay with you
or me or anybody else picking
>> apart his scripture that they choose to
believe in and rejecting the parts they
disagree with that they don't like
>> my brother
>> is that is Allah okay with that
>> dear brother you really don't think
things get lost in translation
>> that's not what I asked remember direct
on topic honest
>> so if that's so now I see what you want
to
You want to control the conversation.
This isn't isn't a debate. You want to
control it, man. And and it's cool. I'm
not gonna speak for God. I'm not going
to do that. You know what I'm saying? I
don't even I'm let somebody else up,
man. I'mma let somebody else up.
If you uh if you you get into your
feelings like that, start, oh, you just
want to control the conversation. I
already told you. I gave you the four
rules. Be direct.
Be on topic,
be honest, and be respectful.
You failed in three of them. You were
respectful. I give it to you. Very
respectful guy. Nice guy. You are not
direct. You are not on topic. You are
not honest with the verses.
So, go ahead, man. And just uh this is
on YouTube, brother. So, uh just go
ahead and watch your clip back, man.